let's talk briefly about Hugh Hefner
Hugh Hefner the founder of Playboy
magazine and Playboy Enterprises has
died at the age of 91 as a result of
what is being reported as natural causes
playboy is one of the most recognizable
brands it started 64 years ago
controversial in many ways controversial
and how it portrayed women but also very
important in the discussion about media
decency censorship and civil rights I
actually believe that the story of Hugh
Hefner is one that really many people
aren't aware of in terms of the
significance of what Hefner did in
favour of civil rights and integration
and racial equality early in the 20th
century in the United States playboy was
publishing in its magazine in terms of
before I get to that some of the things
that playboy did which were really quite
innovative Playboy was publishing in its
magazine fiction from everybody ranging
from Ray Bradbury author of Fahrenheit
451 to Gabriel Garcia Marquez to
Margaret Atwood to Jack Kerouac and and
Kurt Vonnegut in a magazine with naked
women right the Playboy interviews were
absolutely fascinating pieces of media
history and it spurred you know there's
this joke now about oh you've got
playboy yeah I just have it for the
articles it's a joke but it actually did
start with playboy having really really
good material in it that one could
actually read but just as importantly
Hugh Hefner actively fought against Jim
Crow laws in the south with integrated
Playboy Clubs in Miami and in New
Orleans and at the time it sounds like
no big deal but at the time it was a big
deal to have groups of people from
different races performing in front of
audiences that were also racially
integrated and Hugh Hefner was super
clear about the the sort of desire to
have that and have it be exactly what it
was he fought against so-called sodomy
laws sodomy laws you might remember
served as the basis for a lot of
anti-gay discrimination then and later
in the American legal system and I think
it's really easy I'm getting so worked
up I almost just destroyed my mouth
I think it's super easy to say ah Hugh
Hefner playboy objectified women in a
magazine period we can have that
conversation legitimate conversation to
have but Hugh Hefner was a true
progressive on everything from speech to
media regulation to civil rights and
LGBT rights and by the way when we hear
that our current president started from
nothing and built his real-estate empire
other than of course having the super
rich dad who was already a real estate
success story in New York and getting
that very small loan of a million
dollars from his dad Hugh Hefner took
out a mortgage in 1953 got a bank loan
of $600 got $8,000 together from 45
investors and ultimately launched
playboy playboy and its trademarks now
generate a billion dollars per year in
sales
everyone is flawed but Hefner did some
very very interesting things and some
very very good things as well and he has
died at the age of 91